reed hastings scheint so zu sein wie
seine dvd praktisch unverwüstlich er hat
die welt des films und des fernsehens
verändern
zweimal wir vermieten dvds zum
pauschalpreis ganz einfach er ist einer
der leute die die videotheken getötet
haben werden nichts lieber getan als
netflix abzuwehren er trotzdem seinen
kritikern und setzte auf filme per post
als dvd es noch eine neuheit die meisten
investoren dachten dass netflix nur ein
weiteres dot com ist eine kleine nischen
idee dass die leute kein abo wollen und
es sich nie durchsetzen wird
setzte sich durch sein wert stieg
innerhalb von zwölf jahren auf zwölf
milliarden dollar bis ein fataler fehler
das wachstum stoppte netflix abonnenten
flüchten massenhaft mehr als 800.000
kunden haben im letzten quartal
gekündigt einige leute sagten es wäre
als hätten aliens die macht über seinen
körper übernommen hastings ist
entschlossen den ruf seines unternehmens
wiederherzustellen
so kommt wie ein typischer silicon
valley manager sehr zurückhaltend aber
er ist einer von denen die gewinnen
müssen
[Musik]
zehn zwölf jahren als wir mit netflix
angefangen haben nicht das internet noch
über aol ein wald aber uns wurde klar
hey die netzwerke werden wachsen und
alle videos werden klicken watch videos
im internet alle
reed hastings machte karriere indem er
die zukunft vorher sah zuerst mit einem
software-tool dann mit einer einfachen
dvd und einer 32 cent briefmarke
sie werden niemanden finden der mehr
antrieb hat als reed hastings denkt er
denkt ständig über die nötigen
strategischen veränderungen
ist ein unglaublich zielstrebiger
innovativer mensch der so klug ist wie
werden unfassbar klug einfach
ist einer dieser typen die nicht gerne
viel über sich selbst
wer glaubt dass seine taten zeigen wie
gut er ein unternehmen führen kann
getreu diesem motto wollte er auch mit
uns nicht über sich selbst reden
hastings wurde 1960 in boston
massachusetts geboren und wuchs im
vorort balance auch der ehemalige
gouverneur gray davis ist ein freund von
hastings er stammt aus der mittelschicht
sein vater war anwalt die familie war
nicht sehr wohlhabend bildung war der
grund für seinen erfolg
dazu gehörte ein bachelor abschluss am
boden
er verbrachte einen sommer in einem
ausbildungsprogramm der us-marine
erkannte aber dass das militär nicht zu
ihnen war
er trat dem frieden scorpio
unterrichtete zwei jahre lang und
trampte dann mit zehn dollar in der
tasche durch afrika zu
unterrichten inspirierte ihn sieht der
charlie rose 2005 erzählt
also ich war high school mathelehrer im
schreiben
ich liebe das unterrichten ich habe
highschool mathe unterrichtet und das
war einfach eine fantastische erfahrung
als er in die usa zurückkehrte machte er
in stanford seinen master in informatik
und bekam eine stelle bei dem
technologieunternehmen enwave
corporation mark buchs ist ein start up
investor der hastings zu beginn einer
neuen ära der computer programmierung
kennenlernte
sagte wissen sie bis jetzt entstand
jedes programm das erstellt wurde im
wesentlichen im kopf einer person
aber jetzt kommen wir an den punkt an in
23 15 leute ein programm schreiben
müssen und wenn das passiert gibt es
probleme bei der koordination zwischen
den leuten und das führt zu vielen
fehlern
fehler von denen hastings glaubte sie
beheben zu können er schrieb ein
programm und gründete mit marc box die
firma pure software die alle
perfektionisten wollte hastings die
besten einstellen und tat alles um sie
zu bekommen
damals software manager bei cadence
design systems
ich wollte die firma bei der ich war
nicht verlassen aber dann kam man mit
einem sixpack bier in meine wohnung und
wir fingen an zu reden das ist seine
typische art
lotterie mclane war eine von hastings
ersten investoren und ein
vorstandsmitglied
sobald wir loslegten gab es kein halten
mehr das geschäft verdoppelte sich jedes
jahr vier jahre in folge eine richtige
rakete
1995 hatte peer software den heiligen
gral der startups erreicht dem
börsengang am eröffnungstag schossen die
aktien um 75 prozent in die höhe
ex es war sehr aufregend
1995 waren wir für eine woche der
erfolgreichste börsengang des jahres in
der woche danach ging netscape an die
börse und stellte alles in den schatten
der erfolg brachte hastings auf die
titelseite von usa today vor seinem
auffälligen neuen porsche carrera ein
foto das er später bereuen sollte cliff
adwords technologie reporter bei
bloomberg businessweek
er hatte das gefühl dass er wie eine art
reiches wunderkind dargestellt wurde
dass sein traum lebt obwohl er
eigentlich zeigen wollte dass sein
unternehmen hat gesund pflegt und in
dass er sein leben steckt
zwei jahre später verkaufte er das
unternehmen für 750 millionen dollar und
richtete seinen blick ganz woanders hin
michael kast ist emeritierter professor
für pädagogik der city ich bekam einen
anruf von jemandem von dem ich noch nie
gehört hatte reed hastings der sagte er
wolle nach dem fortkommen und
bildungspolitik studieren ich war mir
nicht ganz sicher warum er daran
interessiert war denn es passte nicht zu
seinem lebenslauf
für hastings war es ein neuanfang
sechs monate lang studierte er und
versuchte dann sich für eine neue art
von schule in kalifornien einzusetzen
und es gelang ihm eines der ersten
gesetze für schulen in freier
trägerschaft durchzusetzen dass
innovation und neue betreiber zuließ und
ein völlig neues konzept für kalifornien
war
[Musik]
auch für hastings gab es ein neues
konzept es ein vorfall 1997 brachte ihn
dazu eine ganze branche neu zu erfinden
glos erinnerte er sich 2005 an eine 40
dollar seines gebühr die eher an einen
filmverleih
ich weiß noch dass ich meiner frau
nichts davon erzählen wollte und dachte
hotel hirt setzte ich schon meine ehe
deswegen aufs spiel als er erzählte ich
hier natürlich
dann dachte ich ich kann doch nicht der
einzige sein der mit solchen säumnis
gebühren zu kämpfen hat über das
internet und die folge es nach darüber
wie das auch ohne funktionieren könnte
fast alles davon mit vhs kassetten they
just that hastings sah die chance in
einem neuen format und einem
überraschenden neuen geschäft dvds per
post aber zuerst musste er herausfinden
ob die scheiben den postweg überleben
würden also habe ich einen haufen cds
eingepackt dvds konnten sie aber nicht
kaufen dann habe sie an mich selbst
geschickt musste dann erst mal 24
stunden warten um zu sehen ob sie ein
stück zusammen mit meiner idee und dann
am nächsten tag und 3 der postbote und
ich riss die umschläge auf und die erste
seit gut aus ich heute sehr gut aus die
dritte sehr gut aus und ich dachte mir
dieser blödsinn wird funktionieren
1998 startete hastings netflix als
erster online dvd verleih die wie die
der heutige redbox präsident mit strom
war einer der mitgründer
wir begannen in einem alten bankgebäude
unser inventar hatten wir in einem alten
tresorraum wir waren vielleicht sieben
acht leute und jeder wollte herausfinden
wie man das unterhaltungsgeschäft
umkrempeln könnte
sie deckten sich bei einzelhändlern wie
best buy mit dvds ein aber es gab ein
problem
kaum ein haushalt hatte einen
dvd-spieler
sie kosteten fast 600 dollar und niemand
wusste wann die billiger werden würden
er hatte alles auf die dvds gesetzt wenn
es die dvds nicht gegeben hätte für
einmal wäre nichts einfach null
[Musik]
beherrschten die branche mit tausenden
von einzelhandelsgeschäften fast überall
denn hastings konkurrenzfähig sein
wollte musste er sich etwas einfallen
lassen spüren und er hatte eine idee die
ein einfach zu bedienendes
gegen eine monatliche gebühr konnten die
mitglieder so viele filme sehen wie sie
wollten ohne seines gebühren er erkannte
dass es keine gute idee ist den kunden
jedes mal eine rechnung über drei dollar
zu stellen also brachte er das
unternehmen dazu ein abo modell
einzuführen das hat alles verändert
diese veränderung wurde durch zwei neue
funktionen begünstigt die warteliste für
filme die benutzer sehen wollten und
computergenerierte empfehlungen die
erstaunlich genau waren michael peca
verfolgt netflix seit zehn jahren
der internet bestellen mechanismus war
innovativ die empfehlungsmaschine war
innovativ und die warteschlange war
innovativ netflix war schon sehr früh
erfolgreich weil sie die ersten waren
die all diese dinge herausgefunden haben
aber trotz aller innovationen war
netflix immer noch kaum auf dem radar
die einnahmen von fünf millionen euro
anfang 2000 verschwanden neben den 4,5
milliarden von dollars nahmen die 900
mal so groß waren wie netflix
in einem cleveren zug hastings auch
seinen größten konkurrenten zu alle
liebten blockbuster blockbuster war das
goldene kind und netflix war so etwas
wie das hässliche stiefkind dass da
jetzt kam und alle dachten nun das ding
wird nicht überleben dem werden keine
beine wachsen es wird sterben wir hatten
probleme kunden zu akquirieren und wir
sahen blockbuster als größte einzel
quelle für verleih kunden
also wandten wir uns an sie und luden
sie ein strategischer partner und
investor zu werden
der unterhaltungsriese von das
unterhaltsam
john and yoko war geschäftsführer von
blockbustern als netflix auftauchte
wir dachten naja wenn wir in dieses
geschäft einsteigen sollten wir die
internetrechte wahrscheinlich nicht für
ein paar prozentpunkte an ein anderes
unternehmen abgeben
deswegen mussten wir immer wider abwägen
ob wir einsteigen oder nicht
ich glaube netflix hatte großes glück
dass blockbuster der schlafende riese
nichts unternommen hat und sie schliefen
weiter demut ist ein gentleman ich
glaube wenn man netflix einen anderen
chef gegeben hätte der ein bisschen
frecher und dreister gewesen wäre hätte
man blockbuster vielleicht dazu
provoziert zu konkurrieren
es gab keinen grund mit blockbuster zu
konkurrieren ende 2008 flix in den roten
zahlen die verluste stiegen auf 57
millionen dollar es hörte sich einfach
an wie eine weitere dort commis de vito
und die meisten investoren waren einfach
davon überzeugt dass netflix eine kleine
nischen idee war die leute wollten kein
abo es würde sich nie durchsetzen
während netflix darum kämpft der
profitabel zu werden madrid hastings
wieder etwas unerwartetes denn er nahm
einen zusätzlichen job in der
staatlichen bildungsbehörde von
kalifornien an jeder von ihnen hat schon
mal versucht große organisation zu die
erste hälfte der schlacht besteht darin
sie auf den richtigen kurs zu bringen
ich jemals in einem schützengraben wäre
hätte ich gerne reed hastings bei mir
denn wir würden über die nächsten
schulausschusssitzung diskutieren und
darüber wie die entscheidung ausfallen
sollte denn sobald eine entscheidung
gefallen war ging er da rein und blieb
standhaft und setzte die reform durch
netflix dagegen war alles andere als
etabliert und ging in den dort kaum
sturzflug über wie sind die helden
gefallen laut einer aktuellen studie von
morgan stanley die mutter hat die
durchschnittliche internet-aktie zwei
drittel von ihrem 52 wochenhoch
eingebüßt
netflix hatte schon lange einen
börsengang geplant der markt in eine
abwärtsspirale gelegt
[Musik]
beim ersten versuch eines börsengangs
sahen wir uns mit vielen hindernissen
konfrontiert
die blase war geplatzt man glaubte das
internetunternehmen keine substanz
hätten es gab die antrags angst es gab
den elfter september
war ein desaster bei dem alles in die
falsche richtung lief
und musste im oktober 2001 auf jeden
dritten mitarbeiter entlassen netflix
stand am rande der katastrophe
ich glaube netflix fette zwischen 99 und
2002 jederzeit untergehen können wenn es
ernsthafte konkurrenz gegeben hätte als
das jahr zu ende ging kam dadurch
die preise für dvd-player vielen und
hastings legte fast jeder neuen box
einen gutschein für eine kostenlose
testversion von netflix bei das geschäft
lief gut
nachdem das unternehmen wieder auf kurs
war wurde der börsengang 2002
wirklichkeit in diversen tricks und tore
die netflix aktie stieg am ersten tag
auf 16 dollar 75 aber es war ein
zweischneidiges schwert terry beobachtet
netflix als internetexperte der
börsengang verschafft netflix viel
aufmerksamkeit nicht nur bei den
verbrauchern sondern auch bei den
konkurrenten und so wurde die konkurrenz
von unternehmen wie walmart und
etablierten anbietern wie blockbuster
immer größer
startete seinen konkurrierenden dienst
im jahr 2003 ein jahr später stieg auch
blockbuster ein wenig wir sind anfangs
ähnlich wie netflix er startet nämlich
mit einer kostenlosen test
mitgliedschaft eines der schönsten worte
in der amerikanischen sprache ist
kostenlos und das brachte uns ein
ordentliches wachstum
blockbuster nahm außerdem zwei euro
weniger an monatsgebühren was einem
hässlichen preiskrieg auslöste netflix
senkte den preis
bester kontakte
walmart unterbot beide also gingen
blockbuster noch weiter runter bei einer
telefonkonferenz am ende des jahres
erklärte hastings blockbuster hat uns
mit allem beworfen außer mit der
küchenspüle
und einige wichtige mitglieder des
managementteams saßen in meinem büro und
hörten der telefonkonferenz zur jemand
sagte warum schicken
tag haben wir eine verschickt damit war
die feindschaft natürlich im karton
der harte wettbewerb forderte seinen
tribut
die netflix aktie stürzte um 75 prozent
der analyst michael pachter kommentierte
netflix ein wertloses stück scheiße das
von wirklich netten leuten geleitet wird
wer ist ich war überzeugt dass
blockbuster effektiv konkurrenz machen
würde und ich dachte wenn blockbuster
entschlossen war seine kunden zu
behalten dann würden at flix
verschwinden
nicht kampflos
er opferte gewinne um die konkurrenz
zurück zu drängen und das wachstum
aufrechtzuerhalten
es wurde ein zimmer bus krieg
sie waren der meinung dass netflix nicht
in der lage sein würde so einen
wettbewerb zu überleben war und das
blockbuster und dann walmart
letztendlich nur noch die gewinne aus
mit flex herauspressen würden und und
ich glaube was beide unternehmen in
ziemlich kurzer zeit herausfinden war
dieses geschäft war viel schwieriger als
sie dachten
während der kampf mit blockbuster und
walmart tobte erlitt hastings einem
persönlichen rückschlag vier jahre lang
hatte er sich im kalifornischen
bildungsministerium für eine schulreform
engagiert doch als er mehr zweisprachige
programme forderte warfen ihn die
demokratischen abgeordneten raus es war
ein schlag für ihn das kam überraschend
und es war sicher auch demütigend von
seiner eigenen politischen partei
abgelehnt zu werden
aber er sagte wenn das ein grund es mich
aus dem schulausschuss zu werfen dann
gehe ich stolz und erhobenen hauptes
hastings konzentrierte sich auf den
kampf seines unternehmens an das dvd
versand geschafft und mitte 2005 begann
sich das blatt zu wenden
er zog sich zurück und überließ netflix
seine kunden im tausch gegen
verkaufsförderung
blockbuster gewann zwar abonnenten
verlor aber hunderte von millionen
dollar nun war häftlings an der reihe in
jemanden als netto zu bezeichnen wir
sind nicht gegen bot gestern das sind
alles nette leute wir wollen einen
besseren service anbieten damit die
kunden uns vorziehen und das führt
gegebenenfalls dazu dass sie dichtmachen
2007 sagte and yoko auf dem sundance
filmfestival in utah dass er zu einem
treffen mit hastings eingeladen wurde um
über einen gilt er hätte es lieber
gehabt dass netflix blockbuster online
kauft aber wir haben ihm eine fusion es
blieb beim gespräch weil es bedenken
wegen der kartellvorschriften gab
2008 war ein tier koubek und blockbuster
zog sich aus dem online geschäft zurück
sie haben hunderte von millionen dollar
verloren als sie versuchten mit netflix
zu konkurrieren und dafür hatten sie
einfach nicht das geld man wusste dass
sie irgendwann aufgeben mussten und
genau das ist dann ja schließlich
passiert es war ein triumph für netflix
bastings hatte sich das geschäft mit den
filmen per post gesichert
2007 lieferte das unternehmen die
milliardste dvd aus
da war es schon dabei netflix mit einem
dienst neu zu erfinden er versprach die
dvd überflüssig zu machen video
streaming im internet das war es was er
von anfang an bei netflix vorausgesehen
hatte es dauerte nur ein jahrzehnt bis
es auch so eintraf wenn es etwas gibt
worauf man sich verlassen kann wenn das
die technologie die bandbreite immer
schneller und billiger macht die
bandbreite mark billiger gewesen sein
aber nicht die shows im gegensatz zu
dvds brauchte netflix für jeden
gestreamten film eine lizenz und die
gebühren waren astronomische andrew
williams team vom hollywood magazin
soweit
ich glaube die titel mit denen netflix
anfing waren wahrscheinlich der unterste
bodensatz das waren die filme oder
fernsehsendungen die schon lange
vergessen waren nicht die besten sachen
ich erinnere mich an eine spöttische
bemerkung und eine notiz darüber dass
niemand operation kleinhirn drei sehen
wollte als der film anfang der
neunzigerjahre rauskam
also wollten sie in 2007 sicher auch
nicht singen
selbst wenn sie es wollten netflix
konnte nur auf ein gerät streamen
nämlich den pc
wir sehen uns keine filme auf unserem pc
an wer streamt auf den pc wen
interessiert so was das war verrückt wir
dachten wirklich es sei verrückt also
tastings diesen service den abonnenten
kostenfrei an als er dann ankündigte wir
werden das kostenlos anbieten da waren
wir uns sicher dass er verrückt ist
er bemühte sich auch um mehr inhalte
fügte in weniger als zwei jahren 11.000
titel hinzu und sicherte sich einen
bahnbrechenden vertrag für erst
aufgeführte filme und serien muss ein
paar jahre zurückgehen zu dem deal den
sie mit stars abgeschlossen haben
dadurch bekam sie großartige filme aus
der sony bibliothek der disney
bibliothek und sie bekam den deal für
nur etwa 20 millionen dollar das war das
schnäppchen des jahrzehnts
es folgten deals mit vielen der großen
studios
es ist mir eine freude ihnen den netflix
ceo reed hastings vorzustellen noch
beeindruckender war wie schnell netflix
das streaming aufnahmegeräte ausweitete
ein enormer erfolg für uns und für fast
jedes unterhaltungssystem auf dem
planeten das wachstum hielt an
2011 erreichte die zahl der abonnenten
die 20 millionen marke ein umsatz von
über 2 milliarden dollar weckte die
aufmerksamkeit der branchen goliath
amazon apple google und facebook das
sind alles 800 pfund gorillas das könnte
gefährlich werden für netflix wenn ich
überlege ob es eine zeit gab in der sie
mehr druck ausgesetzt waren mir fällt
keine ein überraschender weise kam der
wirkliche druck nicht von diesen tag
gegangen
sondern von einer reihe eigener viel
entscheidung
im juli 2011 kündigte netflix an seine
abo gebühr um 60 prozent zu erhöhen
800.000 kunden liefen davon zwei monate
später entschuldigte sich hennings
reumütig wir machen dieses video heute
uns persönlich zu entschuldigen er
kündigte an dass netflix sein bvb und
streaming geschäft aufteilen würde die
preiserhöhung blieb aber aus die wie die
bei mail sollte eine neue marke werden
quick star der plan scheiterte auf
kunden und aktionäre flüchteten weiter
wollten abos und aktien loswerden
netflix nun in einer abwärtsspirale war
gezwungen einen rückzieher zu machen
netflix drückt heute den rückspiel knopf
das unternehmen macht eine große
kehrtwende und sagt quick star ist tot
und die dvd und streaming-dienste wieder
unter einem dach
der grund dafür ist einfach die kunden
machen es einfach nicht
entschuldigte sich erneut diesmal dafür
dass er zu schnell gehandelt hat
sechster wurde zum symbol dafür dass
netflix nicht zugehört hat und wir haben
den kurs schnell geändert
erhalten an dvds als teil des marktes
es war ein epischer einbruch netflix
verlor innerhalb von drei monaten was
zwei drittel seines wertes an einem tag
sattem berauben de 2,3 milliarden und
als ob das nicht schon genug wäre
trennten sich netflix und stars dass
netflix die neueren filme von disney und
sony vorenthielt und in eindruck
hinterließ netflix all ihre inhalte und
erhöhe trotzdem die preise
kündigte neue vereinbarungen
er habe nie daran gedacht zurückzutreten
sagte er
er wolle am erfolg von zwölf jahren
gemessen werden und nicht an den fehlern
von zwölf wochen
hat die art und weise wie wir alle über
den konsum von unterhaltung denken
verändert er hat die möglichkeiten wie
man filme bekommt erweitert
ich würde reed hastings und netflix
nicht abschreiben sie kennen ihre
herausforderung und verstecken sich
nicht auf es gibt nur sehr wenige
unternehmen die so viele dinge getan
haben und damit erfolg hatten und
wissen sie zwölf jahre später ist es
wieder eines dieser unternehmen dass man
vielleicht nicht mag über dessen erfolge
man aber nicht streiten kann
[Musik]